Vous les avez vu danser à Ibiza,
vous les avez vu se prendre au jeu à Las Vegas.
Vous allez les adorer à Shanghai !
La ville de toutes les libertés.
Ça pue ! Pourquoi ça pue là ?
C'est quoi ce bazar ?
putain le maroille il est foutu là !
Y'a de la flotte partout là !
C'est quoi ?
C'est ma mère elle m'a offert le maroille.
Pendant ce temps là
y'en a un qu'a laissé la porte du frigo ouverte ok ?
Et maintenant toutes les congèles dedans,
elles sont foutues !
Comme on est à Shanghai.
Je vous rends pas compte comment.
c'est dur de trouver du fromage au Japon hein.
Tu crois quoi espèce..
*Censure*
Bah fallait pas que Djordan et Djézonne ils se battent pour des b'outilles.
C est bon là vas-y va fermer ton c... OH  !
Y'a un nouveau ch'ti qui arrive à la villa.
J'espère que le nouveau ch'ti il va envoyer la pâté.
Pâté quel goût?
Et là, il arrive et on le voit.
Salut, moi c'est Djordane.
C'ment t'appelles?
*cris*
Ah mais oui, mais je te connais, t'es pas de la famille à Steve de Tourcoing?
Ah oui c'est ça.
Oh, tu t'calmes, tu t'calmes un peu là.
Qu'est ce qu'y a, qu'est ce qu'y a là?
- Je sens ta schnek d'ici
- Mais ça va!
Il est pas méchant le nouveau mais juste il a des problèmes au niveau d'la...
...la promiscruité...
P'tain! Qui c'est qui laisse trainer des merdes comme ça dans la baignoire là ?
Oh  ! C'est bon oui !
Voici un poisson...
Djordane! Braiane!
Regardez, Shania elle emmène le nouveau dans sa chambre.
Oh sa mère !
Oh elle va lui mettre la ziquétte, elle va lui mettre la ziquétte !
*agitations*
Toujours ils lui font tous..
Tous ceux qui vivent aussi
PUTAIN PUTAIN
Tous ceux qui viennent ici
*cris de colère*
Dans Boule et Bill, le chien, c'est Milou.
Et oh ça va pas du tout ton truc là c'est pas normal, ça va trop vite, ça pousse trop là.
C'est pas normal!
Et toi, on est tous d'accord pour dire ici que tu parles jamais et on sait pas si t'es un vrai ch'ti ok ?
Et on sait pas si tu sais faire des choses pour montrer que tu sais faire des choses pour travailler dans la night ou pas ?
Alors qu'est ce que t'as à dire ?
Des joies mais aussi des peines
une chose est sure les ch'tis ne vous laisseront pas indifférent.
C'est la reine de la niiight.
On est les ch'tis à Shangaï.
Dans le prochain épisode
vous verrez comment ils vont combatre la race alienne qui est sortie du ventre de Shania.
Qu'est ce tu veux le chat vert, tu rentres pas dans ma ...
Qu'est ce tu fait?
qu'est ta ? Oh noooon